today's video is brought to you by
nordvpn more on them in a bit Allied
propaganda posters during World War II
frequently featured the characters of
the three axis leaders the German one
with the mustache the big jawed Italian
and the stern bespect called Japanese
General the association was intended to
portray the latter as the Japanese
equivalent of the other two totalitarian
leaders in reality prime minister war
minister and army Chief of Staff Hideki
Tojo was never an absolute ruler even
though he concentrated considerable
political and military power into his
hands he was never a dictatoric into the
fuhr or the duche his authority was
always subordinate to Emperor hirohitos
and it was frequently undermined by
political opponents nonetheless his
responsibility in initiating the second
sino-japanese war an extending World War
II to the Pacific Theater is
unquestionable as head of both the
Japanese government and the Japanese
military he would ultimately be
accountable for the brutal treatment of
civilians and prisoners of War but
before we get to the end of tojo's story
let us explore his rise to the top
thank you
Hideki Tojo was born on December 30 1884
in the oate prefecture Honshu Japan he
was the third Son Of hiddenori An
Imperial Army officer and jitose
tokenago daughter of a Buddhist priest
hideki's two older brothers died at a
young age making him the eldest son the
family as such he grew up rather spoiled
by his parents but he endured strict
discipline at school by his own emission
he was never a particularly gifted
student but he compensated for his lack
of talents with sheer determination this
attitude to schoolwork provided him with
an excellent memory for detail and
almost manic Obsession for procedure and
discipline which would serve him well in
later life after finishing school Hideki
joined the military Academy graduating
in 1905 as a second lieutenant in the
Cavalry the russia-japanese war had just
concluded with the victory for Japan
Hideki who was commissioned too late to
join in the fight his father hiddenori
had served with the rank of General but
was repatriated with the case of
beriberia severe deficiency of vitamin
B1 this disease was indicative of the
poor diet of Japanese soldiers and a
reflection of the poor Logistics of
Tokyo's military an obsession with
securing resources would impact tojo's
later decisions in 1909 Hideki married
his fiancee Ito katsu a rather
Progressive move on his part Ito was a
college student unusual for Japanese
women at the time and the marriage had
not been arranged by their parents the
couple was apparently a happy one and
they eventually had seven children young
officer Tojo furthered his military
education by attending the Army staff
College graduating in 1915. three years
later Toto sir briefly in Siberia
without seeing any combat this operation
always part of the anti-bolshevik Allied
intervention in the Russian Civil War an
experience that developed tojo's
anti-communist positions in fact he
identified Russia and later the Soviet
Union as Japan's main antagonist in East
Asia after his Tour of Duty in Siberia
Tojo traveled to Germany as a military
attache in 1919. while there he was
strongly impressed by the concept of
Total War espoused by General Eric
ludendorff to oversimplify this approach
involved converting industrial and
agricultural sectors to full-scale
military production in times of war on
his long way back to Japan Tojo crossed
the United States by train in 1992. the
Fanboy of industrial production he
should have been impressed by the
potential of the US in this department
and yet tojo's impression of America was
of a rich yet decadent country
ill-suited for a total war effort and
his dislike of the U.S was heightened in
May 1924 when the American Congress
passed the Johnson Reed act which
severely restricted immigration from
Asian countries in the following years
Tojo dedicated all of his time to
administrative work within the Army
barely seeing his children his pen
always truly mightier than his sword it
seems and in 1928 he received a
promotion to Colonel and an appointment
as bureau chief of the army it was in
this position that he received the
nickname kamasori or the razor a nod to
his ruthless bureaucratic efficiency
while in this capacity the Razer
networked with young officers and in May
1929 they created a study group called
the one evening Society its members
sought to modernize the Japanese
military according to the German model
of Total War they antagonized the
descendants of ultra-conservative noble
families who traditionally had
disproportionate influence over the Army
staff these traditionalist groups in the
early 1930s merged into the Imperial Way
faction or kodoha they promoted worship
of the Emperor Hirohito despised the
involvement of economy and Industry and
warfare emphasized fighting Spirit above
all and advocated for the Army to
overthrow the civilian government Tojo
and his one evening friends instead
supported the opposing control faction
or to see her they were also staunchly
loyal to the emperor yet they argued
that the military had to cooperate with
civilian institutions as well as the
economic and Industrial Elites an
inevitable confrontation began Brewing
Colonel Tojo continued his steady rise
within the Army ranks heading the
military investigation department within
the ministry of war in 1933. the
following year he received a promotion
to Major General and an appointment as
commandant of the military academy in
March of 1934 the other diligent and
Studio Dojo authored an essay in which
he fused the Notions of fighting Spirit
Away the concept of Total War in this
piece he argued that the Japanese had
Superior willpower compared to their
potential enemies especially the Soviet
Union the United States Britain and
France this Superior willpower should
have been applied to all aspects of
society the economic political and
Military sectors had to work in
cooperation to secure future victories
the only way to ensure such coordination
was through a monolithic near
totalitarian state so far Tojo had
written a lot about war without ever
fighting in one he soon though would
have a taste of a more operational
command when in September of 1935 it was
appointed head of the campaign tie in
manchuco you see the Japanese empire had
occupied areas of Manchuria northeastern
China since the russia-japanese war
during the 1920s a government-backed
corporation developed the South
Manchuria Railway in the region on
September the 18th 1931 a tract of the
Railway was blown up ostensibly by
Chinese troops but the incident was a
false flag attack designed to justify a
Japanese Occupation of Manchuria on
March 1 1932 the occupied area became
the puppet state of manchukwo manchukwo
always governed o with an iron fist by
the kwatung Army a large Detachment of
the Imperial Japanese Army which over
time became almost independent from
Tokyo the Imperial Army included a unit
called campetai present also in manchuco
sometimes described as the Japanese
gestapo the campetai was a military
police under tojo's Direction the
mantuquo campetai became the efficient
arm of a police state which he would put
to good use in February 1936. on the 2nd
of that month the Rivalry between the
Imperial where in the control factions
within the Army came to a head when a
group of Imperial Way young officers
tried to overthrow the government the
minister of War General Iraqi feared
that the Mutiny could extend the quantum
Ali and ordered its Chief of Staff
General edagi to take preemptive
measures aditigaki set his razor to work
Tojo was opposed to the Imperial way but
on a personal level he was friends with
one of the coup's leaders Colonel Nagata
that he confessed privately to his wife
that he was moved by the tragedy of the
rebels whose Act was doomed to fail
nonetheless Toto obeyed the superior's
orders and unleashed the campaitai
identifying and arresting any officer
suspected of being in cahoots with the
coup the February Mutiny was utterly
crushed both in Japan and manchukwo and
tojo's Swift action had impressed his
superiors back in Tokyo in January 1937
he received a further promotion to a
lieutenant general and in March he
replaced his old boss sit to garki as
Chief of Staff of the quantum Army
General Tojo had designs of his own now
that he led a large Force bordering the
feared and hated Soviet Union in June
1937 the Soviets had occupied the
kanchatsu island on the river Amur
marking the border with manchukwo Tojo
immediately ordered one division to
retake control of the disputed Island
this was a hostile act against a
bordering foreign power and completely
unsanctioned by the government by the
way in fact the Army general staff not
only didn't approve they overruled
tojo's orders but the Razer was not done
with clamoring for war with a cooler
head he reasoned that a war with the
Soviet Union would have been
unsustainable with a hostile China south
of manchukwo on June 9 1937 Tojo
dispatched to telegram to the war
Ministry erasing the alarm about the
build-up of forces under Chinese
nationalist leader Chiang Kai-shek he
advised urgent action to be taken before
the Chinese became too strong less than
a month later on July the 7th
sino-japanese tensions erupted at Nicole
Chao or Marco Polo Bridge in this
incident Japanese and Chinese units
engaged in separate military exercises
and ended up firing at each other this
single firefight quickly spiraled into a
full invasion of mainland China the
second sino-japanese war had thus begun
General Tojo had a chance to test his
battle skills at last in August of 1937
he commanded an expeditionary force of
150 000 Japanese Mongolian Manchurian
troops into the chaha province of inner
Mongolia operation jihar was a large
enveloping movement designed to outflank
Chinese troops in peaking modern-day
Beijing Dojo deployed three mechanized
brigades but dispersed his tanks in an
infantry support role one of his
subordinates General Sakai argued that
armor was more effective in Mast
concentrated attacks he was right but
Tojo could not accept critics and had
Sakai sacked in any case Chinese troops
in the area had no tanks whatsoever and
Tojo was able to achieve Victory after
all on August 27th his forces conquered
the city of calgar modern day Zhang Jia
Cole with the inner Mongolia region
under Japanese control and a victory
under his belt Tojo planned his next
ambitious move staging a border incident
with the Soviets to spark a war with
Stalin let's be honest about passwords
look either you or someone you know is
using that same password for Netflix
bank account Instagram and half a dozen
a dozen two dozen maybe other things yes
it happens and it's even got a name it's
called credential stuffing and it's the
number one way that account hacking
takes place these days One login gets
leaked onto the dark web and suddenly
everything is compromised yes there are
a lot of Bad actors out there on the
inter but fortunately today's video is
sponsored by nordvpn which is helping to
give internet users all the tricks and
tools of a proper 21st century online
experience you might have heard me talk
about nordvpn before you can encrypt
your internet day to remove your online
activity to another location with just
one click either for Superior security
or new streaming options and look all of
that is still true nordvpn has thousands
of servers spread across 59 countries
but the vpns give you access to many
more options than just new TV with
nordvpn you really can do it all that
includes utilizing their threat
protection upgrade which blocks ads
eradicates web trackers checks for
malware and more right up as part of a
unique deal you guys can get a two-year
plan at a huge discount plus an
additional four months for free and if
you change your mind they offer a 30-day
money-back guarantee all you got to do
is head to nordvpn.com bio again that's
nordvpn.com bio for a two-year deal at a
huge discount plus four free months on
top of that as a bonus or just follow
the link in the description box below
and now today's video
foreign
[Music]
did take place in July and August 1938
at lake kalasan and a pretty serious one
of that 1 300 troops died on both sides
and a furious Hirohito intervened to
stop the madness but Tojo was not around
at that time in May 1938 his old boss
General itagaki had become minister of
war in the cabinet of prime minister
Kano and titagaki needed a trusted Vice
minister so was good old Razer
interested in the position and of course
he was but this time Dojo was not
content with pushing pencils on behalf
of his boss and he sought more
visibility in November he addressed a
conference of industrialists with a
rousing nationalistic speech his
rhetoric attacked the Chinese the
British the Americans and especially the
Soviets he predicted that they would
soon be at war with Japan Tojo warned
his audience to prioritize War
preparations over civilian production in
the near future the speech made it to
the papers at home and abroad leading to
a drop in the Tokyo Stock Exchange the
Japanese Parliament questioned the war
and prime ministers about this faux pas
prime minister was embarrassed by the
Halt barkle and ensured that Tokyo Could
Do no harm the general was reassigned to
a non-political job in December 1938 as
Inspector General of the Army Aviation
Tojo held their position until July 1940
when the then current cabinet led by
prime minister yanai always dissolved
conno resumed power and oh when
appointing his new cabinet he chose
Hideki Dojo as war minister and this may
seem counter-intuitive given the history
but the truth is that both men had much
in common they both worshiped the
emperor and both advocated for Japan to
take a leading role in East Asia by
creating a greater East Asia
co-prosperity sphere but unlike Dojo
Kono had no plans to expand the conflict
to other powers in the region and he
hoped to find a peaceful settlement of
the second sino-japanese war but these
plans would be foiled by Tojo and
foreign minister matsulka Toto intended
the war to continue against China until
total Victory and the major obstacle to
this goal was the Embargo on vital
resources especially crude oil enacted
by the United States Tojo and matsoka
their before pressure of the cabinet
into forming an alliance with Nazi
Germany and fascist Italy The tripartite
Pact of September 1940 which was
intended by Tojo as a guarantee against
potential American aggression relations
with Washington deteriorated further
when Japanese troops moved into
Indochina to cut off the Chinese army
supply lines in cooperation with the
British and the Dutch government the U.S
froze Japanese assets abroad
establishing an economic blockade cono
and Emperor Hirohito considered
re-establishing friendly relations with
Western Powers but Tojo maintained his
hard line according to him the only way
to secure success in China and
strengthen Japan for the eventual
inevitable confrontation with the Soviet
Union was to strike first against
America and not only against the U.S
Europe had been at War since September
1939 Germany and Italy's aggression had
weakened the military presence of
Britain France and the Netherlands and
Southeast Asia as stated by Tojo in his
own diary the time was ripe to conquer
their colonial Holdings seizing their
Bountiful oil at Food reserves Kono
tried to persuade Dojo to seek
diplomatic solution but facing
continuous and transients that prime
minister resigned in October 1941 and
yet another counter-intuitive move
Hirohito and his advisors appointed
General Tojo as the new head of the
government they hoped that tojo's
Devotion to the emperor would eventually
cause him to stop the saber rattling but
they had underestimated the razor's
determination the new prime minister
maintained his earlier brief as war
minister and appointed himself as home
minister too this move ensured he could
quell any internal unrest stemming from
a decision to go to war craftily the
sold the move as amines to quell on rest
should Japan not go to war later he
would accumulate job titles minister of
Education minister of Commerce and
Industry and Minister of Foreign Affairs
in other words Dojo aims to concentrate
all aspects related to indoctrination
propaganda and the conduct of the war
into his hands
on November 17 1941 Tojo dropped any
pretense of seeking diplomatic terms
with the United States in a speech to
Parliament he warned any third power for
example America from interfering in the
sino-japanese war meanwhile the Army and
Navy Chiefs of Staff had been drafting
plans for simultaneous attacks against
U.S bases in Pearl Harbor the
Philippines Wake Island and Guam British
possessions in malar Singapore and Hong
Kong would also be targeted the aim was
to extend Japanese defense lines well
beyond their home islands and mantrico
and to seize natural resources Within
These new borders in achieving these
goals through a lightning fast Victory
Tojo also hoped that Western Powers
would immediately capitulate the
decision to launch these attacks was
taken at the Imperial conference on
December the 1st and then came December
the 7th the day that will live in infamy
shortly before Japan's fighter bombers
mauled the U.S Pacific flee to Pearl
Harbor Toto wrote this entry in his
diary December the 7th Sunday
Sunny 1100 hours consultation with
Emperor discussion of the secretary of
the cabinet hoshino and Kido Lord Keeper
of the privy seal about commencement of
hostilities against U.S Britain and
Holland tojo's plans succeeded
spectacularly and Japan's sudden
expansion made him immensely popular
with the Japanese people he did not shy
away however from admitting that the war
in the Pacific would be long and hard in
a speech on January 21 1942 he admitted
that quote the present war will become a
prolonged one in order to fulfill the
purpose of the war the whole nation must
persevere in whatever difficulties and
tribulations with a firm conviction of
ultimate victory
the Prime Minister had Consolidated
considerable power in his hands but he
was still bound to the rules of the
Imperial Constitution this meant that he
needed full support of the parliament to
sustain the war effort now in theory all
political parties had been merged into
an organization called Imperial rule
assistance association
iraa the aim was to create unity in the
Japanese political Spectrum in times of
War but the iraa I was never equivalent
to a monolithic or powerful party like
the Nazi or fascist parties in fact the
majority of seats the Japanese
Parliament were held by members of
parliament not affiliated to the iraa
Parliamentary elections were expected on
April the 30th 1942 and Tojo knew that
he had to swing parliament's majority
into the iraa fold to do so he invested
more than 2 million yen in bribes and
newspapers and politicians garnering
support for iraa candidates his efforts
were compounded by the shock of April
the 18th Doolittle Raid this was a
daring American bombing raid over token
which proved that the U.S had the will
and resources to strike back it also had
the unexpected effect of stealing the
Japanese people's resolve to continue
fighting and thus support tojo's
military policies as a result 381 of
tojo's pet candidates entered the darts
securing a solid majority for the iraa
the Doolittle Raid had also another
unfortunate consequence most of the
pilots who took part in the action crash
landed in China and were helped by
civilians tojo's military Unleashed a
retaliatory campaign torturing and
murdering 250 000 Chinese civilians
despite his electoral Victory Tojo found
himself at odds with other members of
the political Elite for example
following the Battle of Midway from June
the 4th to the 7th 1942 he was
challenged by foreign minister Togo in
our battle the Japanese Navy had been
bested by its American counterpart
losing eight vessels and 248 planes toga
pointed out that the razor quote was
guilty of flagrant non-feasons in
carrying out urgently needed moves for
increasing fighting Power the Togo Dojo
Feud reached its climax in November 1942
when the prime minister created the
greater Asian Ministry snatching the
administration of occupied territories
off of the hands of foreign Ministry
Togo argued that this move would divide
Japan's strategy in foreign affairs and
challenge Tojo to resign a cabinet
crisis loomed and Hirohito intervened by
asking Togo shigenori to resign instead
before a Ministry fell into the grasp of
Mr Razer the next rival in line was the
Army Chief of Staff General tsugiyama
who criticized hojo's Grand strategy for
the war in the Pacific Dojo secured the
support from the Navy and excluded Tsui
armor from his next plans formalized at
an imperial conference on December 31
1942. on that occasion Tojo ordered the
military to abandon the defensive
positions of Guadalcanal and Buna and
launch an offensive against Port
morrisby Papua New Guinea both decisions
proved to be a mistake the former
encouraged the U.S tragedy of
island-hopping or Progressive
encroaching towards the Japanese home
Island the latter met with defeat
against an Australian counter-offensive
Tojo blamed these serpax on his lack of
total Authority military political
colleagues argued against giving him
free pointing out that Germany's
setbacks were due to Hitler's
micromanagement of all things military
Dojo replied to this Fury Hitler was an
enlisted man I am a general but they had
a point concentration of power does not
yield good results in times of War those
protests fell on deaf ears and Tojo
continued to hog Ministry and
high-ranking positions in April 1943
became minister of Education in November
minister of Munitions in February 1944
Tojo appointed himself Army Chief of
Staff an open violation of the
Constitution what was worse by absorbing
all key positions Tojo was left without
scapegoats to blame for losing the war
the turning point was the fall of the
Pacific island of Saipan on July the 9th
1944 a disastrous defeat the duchin a
privy Council of Elder Statesman advised
Hirohito to remove Tojo from power and
the emperor delivered Tojo was forced to
resign and retire from the Army on July
the 20th had he not resigned an Army
Major sonoda was ready to assassinate
him with the potassium cyanide bomb
it was customary for former Prime
Ministers to immediately join the Jew
Shin but Hirohito did not invite Tojo
until February 1945 which may have been
a calculated slide even after joining
the privy Council it was clear that the
Razer had lost his slashing power
following the fall of yet another prime
minister in April 1945 Tojo put forward
a candidate friendly to the Army but his
plans were quashed by the intervention
of Navy Admiral okada he was less
amenable to a continuation of the war at
any cost a war that despite Japan's
strenuous resistance was orbit lost the
Allies had retaken almost all of their
territories China's forces were on the
rise Hiroshima and Nagasaki suffered the
first ever atomic bombings in history
and if that wasn't enough August the 9th
tojo's Nemesis the Soviet Union finally
invaded Manchuria in force in an
unprecedented act on August 15 1945
Emperor Hirohito spoke on the radio
announcing Japan surrender on September
the 2nd as the Allies began the
occupation of Japan Dojo retreated to
his private home conscious he would soon
be arrested for his involvement in war
crimes the former General can considered
committing suicide for some time but was
dissuaded by the new war minister
shimamura shimamura advised surgery to
postpone his deed until he had taken
responsibility for starting the war thus
sparing the emperor from going to trial
but on September 11 1945 as occupation
authorities and journalists gathered
outside of time Dojo decided to act he
asked a doctor to Mark the location of
his heart with ink and then he fired a
shot with his service pistol the bullet
barely missed the heart and American
Military doctors managed to save his
life he would go on trial as a class a
defendant in front of the international
Military Tribunal for the Far East for
war crimes proceedings began on May the
3rd 1946 with questioning conducted by
Chief prosecutor Joseph Keenan
International observers remarked how
Tojo depended himself with dignity
initially asserting that Japan was
innocent of aggression as War had been
forced upon its people as the trial
continued Tojo gradually admitted
responsibility for ordering the December
1941 attacks claiming that the emperor
was blameless he initially rejected
charges of Cruelty against prisoners War
claiming that they endured the same
hardships the average Japanese soldier
but in this case he eventually admitted
responsibility this was another move to
protect the emperor from prosecution the
trial ended on November 11 1948 with a
conviction for crimes against peace
crimes against humanity and war crimes
the sentence death by hanging to be
carried out on December the 23rd
American Occupational authorities kept
his Pace a burial of well-guarded Secret
for decades wary that it may become a
rallying point for Japanese ultra
nationalists only in June 2021 was it
revealed that tojo's remains had been
cremated and his ashes scattered over
the Pacific Ocean